erasmus+ meet Theo Rasmussen Elena meet
Theo Rasmussen carmella is a teacher
she's just returned from a job shadowing
placement in Germany with erasmus+ the
school she visited is pioneering
effective ways to engage pupils from
disadvantaged backgrounds carmella can't
wait to tell the head teacher and other
colleagues about what she learned manolo
is Spanish he met Carmela on his Erasmus
year at roskilde University a global law
firm took him on after he graduated and
he's been in Denmark ever since ah still
in love after all those years he later
none Elena is off on a youth
volunteering placement in Italy she'll
be helping older people learning
computer skills good experience for next
year when she'll be a college training
as a software engineer Adam became good
friends with Marek when he was on a
European work placement in Poland Adam
now has more international connections
than he can count and thanks to his
international experience with a green
energy firm a local renewables company
will hire Adam as an apprentice once
he's passed his exams
erasmus+ isn't just for Erasmus ins ask
your youth organization school college
or university to help you to experience
erasmus+ if you'd like to find out more
visit ECT Europa EU forward slash
Erasmus hyphen plus will join the
conversation on social media